In terms of non believer and believer there's. Um,
when you say believer, you also are kind of implying this, um,
uh, the,
that the idea that aliens have visited or had made direct contact with humans in
some form. Um, there's also the,
the exploration and the idea of just alien,
intelligent intelligence is out there in the universe. You know,
the Drake equation estimating how many
intelligent civilizations may be out there. How many have ever existed?
How many of us to communicate with us? I mean,
when you just zoom out from our own little selfish perspective of
earth and look at the entirety, let's say the Milky way galaxy,
but maybe even the universe does the idea that they're intelligent civilizations
out there,
something that you're excited about or something that you're terrified about?
That's a good question.
So basically I would say I'm not so keen on it.
Um, I think that our relationship with technology as it is,
and as it, as I hope it will go, will help us, um,
survive. Okay. Um,
I don't think we're equipped to do it as we stand now,
but I think that if we can up our game or let's just put it this way,
if technology is an extension of ourselves, which it actually is,
it will help us because he'll probably be smarter than us. Okay.
It'll help us survive in the ways in which it determines best. Okay. That said,
um, if there are,
non-human intelligences out there and they have more
advanced, you know, obviously technologies than us and they actually come,
um, uh, the history of human engagement with,
you know,
other cultures has not gone well for cultures that are
less aggressive. So you see what I'm saying? Like,
it's not a good idea.
Well, I wonder where we stand on the war, human STEM,
the full spectrum of aggression.
Well, heck where are we now, Lex? I mean, we're not too great here.
We're still aggressing against each other.
No, I know, but that, that will give us the benefit, right? Like, Oh,
all you're saying, I thought, okay. I see.
I just have a sense that there may be a lot of intelligence is out there that
are less aggressive because they've evolved past it.
No, I know we can't assume that, but.
I, if we can't assume it, then I'm going to assume the worst.
Well, that's, that's, uh, uh,
despite the fact that I am a Russian and think that life is
suffering, tend to assume not the best, but I,
I tend to assume that there is a best core to a,
to creatures, to people and to creatures that ultimately wins out.
I think there's an evolutionary advantage to being good
to other living creatures. And so, uh,
ultimately I think that if there's intelligent civilizations out there that
prosper sufficiently to be able to travel across the great spans of
space that, uh,
they've evolved past silly aggression,
that, uh, it's more likely in my mind to be deeply cooperative.
So like growth over destruction,
like growth does not require this structure, I think,
but you see the universe as a,
ultimately a place where it's highly constrained in resources that are necessary
for traveling across space and time.
Then, uh, perhaps aggression is necessary in order to, uh,
aggress against others that are designed to get access to those resources.
I don't know. I tend to try to be optimistic on that front.
I think I'm emotionally optimistic and intellectually non optimistic.
Uh, yeah, I guess I'm that I'm there with you. I,
I T I tend to believe that the, uh,
happiness and deep fulfillment in life has fallen in that emotional place.
Uh,
intellectual places really useful for building cool
new technologies and ideas and so on, but, uh,
happiness is in the emotional place and there, it pays off to be optimistic.
I think.